i just use asian americans as an example
just to show how it's not
race
that is it's not a person's skin color
that is that that that creates their
position in society but it really is
where are they culturally what are they
contributing what are the skills that
they bring to the table
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
episode 129
quick news i have my first live show
it's going to be a q a
because
what else am i going to do
in nashville no i'm just kidding i could
do a live podcast i might do a live
podcast i think it's going to be a q a
check it out it's linked below
i am super excited and kind of nervous
to be honest
well maybe mostly
excited
i hope to see some of you there come
throw your questions at me january 24th
in nashville right before dad goes on
tour and i do the opening part of his
tour
anyway for this episode i'm taking a
quick break from opposing views to bring
you kenny shu
the president of the race blind advocacy
group colorous united author of an
inconvenient minority and the host of
the inconvenient minority podcast where
he battles the elite woke narratives
with provocative conversations about
race identity and culture that challenge
both the left and the right did you know
that if harvard didn't limit enrollment
43 of their students would be asian
american
wouldn't you say limiting enrollment is
kind of racist in today's episode kenny
and i spoke about meritocracy critical
race theory and their role in education
across the us today we covered terms you
may not be familiar with like white
adjacency
and inclusive math and how a shift in
incentives has led to a whole set of
problems like university curriculums
being dumbed down little by little i
hope you find this episode interesting
and if you do be sure to hit subscribe
and remember
you're around nashville you can come
check out my show january 24th
[Music]
kenny shue welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me
where are you located right now
i'm in new jersey
okay cool uh before we get into things
can you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is you do
i'm the president of colorist united we
advocate for race blind america uh i'm
the author of the new book an
inconvenient minority the attack on
asian american excellence in the fight
for meritocracy where i investigate the
consequences
of
anti-racism um in our culture
particularly how it affects
a minority group who doesn't fit the
anti-racist narrative that is asian
americans
um and i'm a journalist and podcaster
the host of the inconvenient minority
podcast and i write for many outlets
so before we get into things i think a
couple of definitions would be good one
what is meritocracy let's start with
that what does that mean meritocracy is
just inequality
it is
why
meritocracy is the idea that you should
be
it doesn't matter where you come from
what your background is you should just
be judged on the basis of your merits
you should be judged on the basis of the
skills that you have the things that you
can contribute and it doesn't matter
about irrelevant characteristics who you
are
um so whether you're black white a woman
or a man
you know gay or straight you know you
should you shouldn't be judged on any of
those things those things shouldn't
matter
uh you should just be judged in what you
can contribute
okay that makes sense
so then the next definition i think we
should cover because we're going to get
into it um crt crt critical race theory
what is that
critical race theory is an idea
developed at harvard law school
which i can get into
uh where that it subdivides people into
races that are privileged and oppressed
whites are at the top blacks are at the
bottom
people of color at the bottom everything
like that and it assumes that the
laws and structures that we have today
are racist and therefore the cause of
the racial inequalities
and inequities that we have in our
society today
okay
okay so
i think we should start with
how has that theory one why what do you
think about that theory whether it's
good or bad and then how has that kind
of infiltrated into the schooling system
in america
i think it's false um
and the reason why is because asian
americans disprove it
there are
asian americans
who basically
should belong
to the victim class of the oppressed
class they face historical
discrimination in this country
um many of them come from countries that
don't even know english many of them
face significant disadvantages they come
in they move into poor neighborhoods
you know chinatown flushing
and it's
their race didn't get them ahead but
because of their sheer hard work and and
and culture cultural values um that any
race can achieve
um they are able to advance beyond their
station 80 percent for example
vietnamese americans come here and they
don't even know english but in one
generation their kids
uh grow up and graduate from college at
a higher rate than even white americans
and that's a result of the fact that
asian americans study twice as many
hours as the average american
they um
they have more stable two parent family
structures
um and i just use i just use asian
americans as an example just to show how
it's not
race
that is it's not a person's skin color
that is that that that creates their
position in society but it really is
where are they culturally what are they
contributing what are the skills that
they bring to the table
yeah
when did you notice critical race theory
and these kind of conversations starting
because i remember when i was little i
don't think there was any of this i
don't remember any of this in school
everyone was pretty much equal at least
where i was from in canada everybody was
equal and everyone was just judged based
on how well they did on tests and that
was it did you know when this kind of
started infiltrating into the
education system
they you know so in critical race theory
critical race theory started
at
um at harvard law school at the behest
of this um individual named derek bell
who was a professor at harvard law
school
and you know it
he
in the 1970s
um you know there was some agitation
about racial inequality in this country
and he posited this theory in our
supposedly colorblind laws and
principles are actually racist and are
still stacked
against black americans
and what happened from there was that
that theory advanced through
educational grad schools columbia
teachers colleges
it became this the norm for for
advancing education in this country so
if you're an educational studies major
if you want to be a teacher or an
administrator you're learning critical
pedagogy in a lot of these colleges and
universities now a lot of these grad
schools and what critical pedagogy says
is
the job of the teacher is to awaken the
individual
to his um to his place in the world
specifically his racial place in this
world um and so that's when you have you
know things like
um we need to teach kids to be aware of
their own privilege we need to teach
kids to be aware of their own oppression
as a result of them being a part of this
collective
so over the past 30 years that has
pretty much transformed the entire
public education system and that has
become
a standard that is now applied you know
in in american
public schools across the nation
so what's the purpose of teaching people
these things like what what was say that
there was a reason to teach people to
you know check their own privilege what
was the goal there
behind all that like what's the positive
benefit of people understanding their
privilege or where they are in society
according to the people who teach crt
the positive benefit is that
you know when an individual becomes
awakened he can he understands how to
uh he unders when he becomes aware you
know the term woke it's funny it
actually comes from
this uh this this critical educator
um
uh who who coined it who coined the term
wide awakeness
when an individual becomes wide awake
about his place in society then he can
learn to deconstruct the structures that
are putting that are putting him down
um it's it's kind of a it's kind of a
sort of
uh plato
uh allegory of the cave kind of thing as
in you know you you you come up into the
light and you're seeing the light now
you're seeing where you actually are and
as a result when you come back down
you're forever changed
um and then you can sort of advance in
society through there and is that
supposed to help people combat it by
becoming more compassionate or like what
what's my question
what are the actions people are supposed
to take once they've become woke
that improves society
um
that improves society
more like deconstruct society more like
deconstruct and build a new society
from the ashes from the ashes
um critical pedagogy
and when you're when you're a kid and um
and and the idea is
you know stalin said um give me a child
for four years and uh i can turn him
into a soldier
um and i'll change his life forever and
that's effectively what critical
pedagogy does you know when you when you
get a child and you make him aware of
his racial oppression and everything
like that then he can come out you know
of that educational system
and
understand you know how to
um
uh
sort of raise solidarity for his race
and advocate on behalf of
you know his own racial oppression
ideals and and and more importantly you
know try to tear down capitalism try to
tear down meritocracy try to tear down
all of the structures that are putting
them down and hopefully install a new
structure and this new structure that is
currently being imagined within critical
race studies is this anti-racist
socialist collective
okay let's get into that a little bit
then because you'd think that
i mean i guess the main goal is to
dismantle what's going on now
and but do they teach
do they teach how they're going to
improve things in the future or is this
all about changing things now and the
future we'll figure it out then
no it's it's critical studies critical
studies means we're critiquing society
oh that's uh yeah it's it's a critical
it's a when you say critical theory the
purpose of the theory is it's a critique
um their their vision they don't really
offer like a separate vision otherwise
that's not happening
it's not helpful at all like here's
everything it's super easy to go into an
establishment point out everything
that's wrong
yeah yeah exactly and you know and you
make this point a lot your father makes
this point a lot this is um
it's easy it's always it's easy to go
and complain and try to tear down
society but if you don't have a
reconstructive vision
for it then
all you're ultimately doing is tearing
down the good along with the bad
and this is and this is the this is why
with my book and my advocacy
um my book an inconvenient minority and
my advocacy i am defending
some of the good principles
that we need to have in our culture
um which is meritocracy
and my belief is one of those principles
that need to be defended
um
america was founded and it's founded
imperfectly but it was founded upon the
idea that you can come the american
dream is you can come from any
background
um and it doesn't matter who you are it
doesn't matter what your background is
uh if you
work hard
you have a chance to be treated on the
basis of that hard work not on the basis
of that background and that's the
principle that i think unifies
americans and provides hope to anybody
from the poor chinese kid and flushing
queens to the black kid and inner city
baltimore um to you know the rural kid
in appalachia
um to know that there is opportunity in
this country and that they won't be
judged based on the things that they
harbor in the past i think that that is
the ideal that we need to resurrect in
this culture today that's the ideal
that's directly under threat by crt
yeah
yeah that makes sense
it makes sense okay i'm going to throw
some other terms at you that you talk
about that i'm not sure if people
everyone's familiar with but sure what
what is what is white adjacency
let's let's assume this this racial
narrative is true let's assume that
whites are at the top
and um blacks are at the bottom and um
and then by the way this is what i was
taught when i was in college uh this is
when was that
um 20 2015
yeah that's when i was in college
and
when i was in college you know we were
pretty much taught if you're white
you're privileged if you're black you're
oppressed and
where did you go i went to davidson
college and what were you studying i was
a math major
yeah so were you learning about this in
math or just philosophy i was learning
about this in my freshman orientation
kayla
wow
yeah
well at least you paid for it
uh yeah i paid dearly for it
that's insane okay yeah
it was uh
but so let's assume that yeah so let's
assume this narrative is true
um and that minorities are at the bottom
but then asian americans become an
inconvenient
minority
and the uh asian americans become this
inconvenient minority in this narrative
because
they
are supposed to be like a person of
color kind of victimized discriminated
everything like that but instead you see
them higher incomes than whites higher
education than whites um and and how
does that how does that come about
um and and the answer is and the answer
that the critical race theorists will
give well it's it's because asian
americans are like closer to whites they
have a proximity towards
right right
they they they're they're betters of
white supremacy they're like sort of um
in bed with the uh and with the with the
uh conspirator so
um that's that's the term white
adjacency you know we we seem to have
even though we don't we're not white we
benefit from
sort of the uh the leaking of white
privilege onto ourselves
is there an explanation about why that
happens
according to them
yeah they would say it's because they
would say it's because well america
um
like
so
their their inherent their inherent
assumption
is that america is stacked against black
people they don't like black people
um and in order to prove you know to to
fix this with with asian americans they
point to well asian americans were used
as props
um sort of between 1960 and 2000
basically america imported a bunch of
asian americans through the immigration
naturalization act of 1965
and these were educated asian americans
you know hard-working asian americans
and they use these asian americans and
they said look at these look at these
minorities this is proof that minorities
can't succeed in this country so black
americans it's really your fault why
you're down so they're sort of using the
critical race ideas that they're using
asian americans as props
um to sort of attack black people
for not succeeding in this country
okay so when you were in college
learning about this stuff did you know
right away
that there was something up for it up
with it like did you were you skeptical
at first or did it sound like something
reasonable when you were there and what
did your friends think
[Music]
well i was um
i would say i was uh open to the idea um
at first because
um
you know
when when i was growing up kind of in a
highly educated area and everything like
that you know you could see that a lot
of these immigrants and everything like
that
were um
you know were highly educated didn't
come from highly educated backgrounds
and
you know it seemed like
okay well maybe that's the reason
maybe maybe there is something going on
here that i don't know but then you know
when i was writing my book an
inconvenient minority i started looking
at the experiences of the poor asians
the poor asian immigrants who come to
this country
and
i can i can tell you the poor asian
immigrants who come to this country who
don't come from any education
they're they're working
extremely extremely hard probably harder
than even some of the highly educated
asian immigrants who are coming to this
country because when you're an immigrant
you you don't have
social privilege you don't have
connections to back you up all you have
are your skills all you have is your
talent
um and
and so that's that's what they put their
bets on they put their bets on their
kids education to achieve generational
mobility so they're really studying
extra hard they're they're spending
weekends in test prep centers um they
are
saving up every extra penny to you know
buy textbooks for their kid
um and and this and to me that showed me
the direct refutation of this it's not
that america wanted
asians to succeed necessarily to prop up
the case against black people it's that
it's that asian americans came in and
and through their sheer hard work and
and effort were able to succeed and
anybody who applies that level of effort
you know will have the same chance
yeah i hate to be this blunt about it
but it seems like a lot of people who
propose critical race theory haven't
actually seen anybody do any hard work
like if they're just saying that doesn't
matter it's like have you seen 80 hours
of work a week
yeah like it doesn't just come to people
right right you know it's it's so funny
that and this is sort of where i was
alluding to earlier in the conversation
uh
critical race theory is an elite
ideology it was made it was
forged in the halls of the ivy leagues
by
people by academics
who
you know sat in
uh their offices theorized about the
world and there's there's a reason why
that's the case because
if you go even if you go to an inner
city public school today population 99
black or you know 95 black five percent
hispanic you know you go to a baltimore
public school and i i've talked with
people there talk with former teachers
i've talked with students there
you know you realize even in those
places
there is a hierarchy that is based not
on race but on confidence how could the
hierarchy be based on race of all of the
students
and nearly all of the teachers are black
you know and there's even in that
hierarchy even in those classrooms there
are some students who want to study more
there are some students who really want
to study hard who really prioritize
their education and there's some
students who are violent gangsters and
they're disrupting the entire classroom
and because they're not disciplined
enough that's the reason why
you know they're
those schools those kids are not given
safe and effective environments to learn
it's really sad but critical race theory
unfairly
puts the blame of the situation on white
people when it's not when these places
it's not about white people at all it's
about what's going on in the culture
within these within these schools and
within these communities
okay
so what's the
is there a solution here do you talk
about any type of solution or how people
should be
acting as opposed to teaching crt
um
or are we just doomed
um i think that i think that
the solution i think first i think
part of recon the issue with sort of
reconstructing the entire solution is
because our
our system has gotten our the crt has
has really come in and and lashed itself
into the all of the educational theories
so it's very hard to extricate ourselves
from that but
i would say to start out we need to
eliminate racial preferences
and we need to put a blanket ban on
racial preferences
in all universities all public schools
high schools everything like that
because racial preferences provides all
of the wrong incentives
basically
if you are
just because of your background you know
you can if you're able to sort of
acquire victim capital
then you're able to get into
universities or get into schools that
you otherwise wouldn't have
um gotten into and what that creates
michaela by the way that creates an
industry of victimhood
it creates it creates an incentive a
strong incentive for people to create
the most victimy story about themselves
that they possibly could so that they
can get the maximum benefit and they can
have the maximum leverage to get into to
whatever prestigious positions they want
to get into
so when you eliminate the industry of
victimhood
because of race preferences then you
then that's when you know the incentive
to
push crt upon people and to push this
racial systemic racism narrative starts
to go away and i think that's when you
can start healing
i want to talk to you guys about a
nordvpn i use vpns when i'm traveling
which i'm doing a lot
way too much
you know they didn't do disney plus in
serbia well they do with nordvpn
can't believe i'm never going back to
serbia after that so hopefully there
aren't any serbians watching anyway i
can't believe there are areas of the
world that actually ban disney disney
and did you know that they're putting
trigger warnings in some disney movies
anyway this isn't supposed to be about
disney this is supposed to be about
nordvpn so i'll get back to that nordvpn
not only are they sponsoring me which is
fantastic but they allow me to get into
netflix wherever i am if i'm somewhere
sketchy i can also protect myself from
getting my information stolen by using
nordvpn in said sketchy areas or if
you're doing something sketchy on the
internet a vpn is probably what you're
looking for
i also like nordvpn because it's the
fastest vpn in the world
it doesn't slow down my internet when
i'm streaming like other vpns i've used
nordvpn's something i'd really recommend
they come in handy in restaurants
airports other countries that block
certain websites and to hide your
information when you want to
nordvpn also has an amazing code for my
listeners grab your holiday season deal
by going to
nordvpn.com
tmpp
to get up to 73 off your nordvpn plan
plus a bonus gift
owed tmpp at
nordvpn.com tmpp like the michaela
peterson podcast i've seen 65 off from
these guys 70 off but 73
unheard of again that's nordvpn.com
tmpp or just use code tmpp or nordvpn's
unheard of deal enjoy the rest of the
episode
so can you give me some examples of this
race based preference like um talk a
little bit about harvard admissions at
the moment the i study the harvard
admissions case because harvard is the
most well-known
race preference practitioner in in the
nation right now it's the most well
it's the most elite
it's the one that everybody wants to get
into
but all not just asians whites blacks
hispanics everybody wants to get into
harvard
and
and so
harvard has
um
and so uh
harvard's race-based policy goes like
this
um if you are asian um or if if there's
um if you are asian you have to score
440 points higher on the sat
to have the same chance of admission as
a black student about 300 points higher
to have the same transmission as a
hispanic student and about 150 points
higher to have the same chance of
admission as a white student um and the
reason why is because
yeah
wow
i can't believe that there's a narrative
that makes this okay
it's what this is this is crt justifies
this though crt justifies this because
because of exactly what we've been
talking about because
according to crt
black people are the most oppressed
therefore they deserve the most
preferences to to rectify for that and
then
um with asians it's kind of a different
story with asians harvard is just
worried that if they admitted based on
merit alone that there would be too many
asians who would get into harvard
because harvard's own office of
institutional research says
that if um if
if if harvard admissions were just a
meritocracy and were just based on the
objective rankings and there wasn't race
put in asians would make about 43
of the university
uh instead they make up about
20
so that's a penalty of half right there
this is racial preferences in action
hmm
interesting
okay so what should people in school do
to kind of is there a way to combat this
or do they just have to keep an eye out
for information that isn't right and
take it with a grain of salt
yeah um well there's a major lawsuit
um that your listeners might be and that
you should be really interested in it's
the students for fair admissions versus
harvard lawsuit
and this lawsuit filed by a group of
asian americans
you know is trying to to take down
harvard's racial preferences system i
think for good reason right because you
know these are the students that are
most harmed by harvard's race
preferences uh harvard's racial
preferences system
and uh this lawsuit
i think um
uh it started in 2014
and it continued in the district court
in 2018 and now it's at the foot of the
supreme court so the supreme court of
the united states
accepts this case
uh it could change the future of race
preferences forever
when is that supposed to happen
it could happen next year
sorry it could happen in 2022 yeah early
2022.
okay that would change things
dramatically
yeah yeah and it would change things um
because
it would um
now now harvard is is doing its very
best to uh try to
defend its system uh it
has actually spent over 40 million
dollars
trying to defend the use of race and
admissions
um
and i think what it shows is that you
know harvard really really wants to
protect
um it's uh this this crt narrative and
harvard really wants to protect um sort
of the um
sort of the multi-colored quilt of its
college that it sort of projects upon
the rest of the world
well it would look really bad if harvard
came out as racist
yeah
they're probably not that into that that
is such a waste of money
i'm not even sure what's gonna happen
with some of these institutions to be
honest if all their teaching is
i mean math is one thing
but
humanities and then it turns out all you
learn in humanities is crt and
you know feminist theory and then you
can't get a job and then that makes you
resentful and then you're in debt and
you're resentful
and then you have a reason to be
resentful because of everything you paid
to learn in university it's like what a
disaster
it's true
um
okay so i guess just purse my personal
story on this
i was going to be an english major
i was interested in studying literature
i was interested in studying the great
books
but you know as i progressed through my
university
um
i realized the rigor of the curriculum
um was low was comparatively lower than
the math classes that i was taking
just a tad
just a tat a little more than a 10.
yeah i switched just i'll let you
continue but i i took classics and
psychology but like bachelor of arts
psychology not science um and i switched
into biomedical science and the
difference in the amount of work between
classics and psychology and biomedical
science i could not believe it it was
like eight times as much work
wow it was crazy and i know that in the
biomedical science like math and physics
those were the the hardest courses but
for anyone listening who hasn't taken
like a science or or math course in
university they're so much more dense
than the humanities courses it's
unbelievable
i don't know how people survive those
those degrees anyway continue right no
exactly exactly um because but here's
the thing uh it doesn't have to be that
way
because
people these english classes can be just
as rigorous as these math and science
classes can be if you just
if the books you're reading with the
formal structure
you know analyzing poetry analyzing
british literature getting a group grip
on that you can have just as rigorous of
an english career i i sincerely believe
that just as rigorous of philosophy
curriculum
as you could math and science but they
actually intentionally make
these majors less rigorous they actually
intentionally make it because they're
concerned about their graduation rates
universities are concerned about their
graduation rates um
and and here's the thing uh race
preferences makes all of this worse
makes all of this worse because what
happens is when you start admitting kids
into universities who are not qualified
on the basis of merit to get into these
universities
and these kids
well you know you obviously it looks
really bad if you have a low graduation
rate they're failing out of classes so
what happens is that you actually have
to make
the majors you have to lower the rigor
of the majors so that these students are
able to actually graduate
and it hurts everybody
but it also make it also waters down the
prestige of the degree
yeah it's a bit surprising that the
universities the universities aren't
more concerned about that
that they're just avoiding that as a
fact which seems fairly obvious although
i guess the idea with crt is you
artificially
you know
bring in a bunch of people who couldn't
get in based on tests under the
assumption that it's because of their
race and that wasn't why they were that
was why they were performing badly on
tests right so then when they get there
and everyone's on
equal terms they should perform well so
i guess if you fully buy into crt
which i suppose these people do
then the assumption would be you
wouldn't have to
make courses easier
because people should all be equal right
i i guess yeah and then the the and then
the alternative what they do what crt
people do and this is like a very clever
maneuver
um is
what happens is that we see that there
are strong
uh
differences right now
in
um average sat scores for example by
race asians score the highest on as an
average sat score than whites then
latinos then black americans there are a
lot of reasons for that nothing to do
with race that you do with race
themselves everything to do with the
environment of the school the
environment of the culture that you grow
up in
but
crt people see this and then they say
well the reason why is because the test
is racist obviously
um
obviously you know the test is stacked
against uh black people
um
you know that's why they're performing
lower and the ironic thing about this is
that that's actually the most racist
thing you can say
to say that black people are inherently
less
good at taking tests um than other
people it's the exact same tests
administered to everybody to test in
math in english you know and and by
saying the test is racist is actually
admitting the natural inferiority of a
certain race which is just the ugliest
thing that i could imagine so crt i
think in an effort to be anti-racist
actually becomes racist
oh yes
certainly
are so
you talked a bit about
vietnamese immigrants and how hard
people work just to catch up given the
fact that they come to a new place can't
speak english don't have any connections
like you said
are there
have you found or spoken with anyone
that had ways to help people along that
are naturally in a more difficult place
because like everyone can agree that if
you grow up in a white family that
already has educated parents that has a
whole bunch of money that that's going
to make your life easier in that way
growing up than being raised by
immigrants with no money who don't speak
english obviously those are two
different situations and one is going to
be more difficult so
are there ways
that you've found that can make it
easier for people or is it just like
that this is the hand you were dealt
buckle down and work
yeah i have a deep deep empathy for
people who um
uh
who grow up in those situations um
of any race
and
what i see
with the success of people who have
grown up in chinatown
and uh or vietnamese town or you know um
and and who have eventually you know
trained their kids and then they become
successful
um
what i actually see funny enough is
a a willingness to go beyond the
parameters of the public education
system
i think that that has to be the number
one thing because the public is and and
a lot of the a lot of it is because of
crt the public education system right
now in the united states is a mess
um it is it is very much a mess
lowering standards
um distract teaching distracting things
now they're implementing critical race
theory in the curriculum
they're not teaching math right one math
educator that i taught you know that i
talked to said that they're now teaching
math and pods like students are supposed
to teach math to each other
um
good luck with that
right
like uh oh you don't um
yeah like that definitely helps um
it doesn't um
um
just because of the way the public
education system is i think you do have
to put a little effort to go beyond the
public
education system either find a good
charter school for your kid or
homeschool your kid
um or find a good private school that
maybe could offer your kid a scholarship
i think you do have to go beyond that i
think your kid it actually is proven
statistically shown that even black
students in new york city
uh who go to charter schools uh close
eventually close 66 percent of the
racial achievement gap in that city
okay
so it's a you take things into your own
hands basically don't rely on the system
at this point
or do at least do enough to question the
system and to
um choose your own options
yeah
dad and i have an interesting project
going on in the next year or so where
we're going to be bringing people
on and building online courses
yeah
so that's going to be fun it's like a
project that's upcoming so that there'll
be people teaching properly like lecture
style proper classes instead of all this
ideology that's
destroying everything at the moment in
the education system
do you think do you think it's better
would you like private schools or
catholic schools or something is there
anywhere that crt hasn't infiltrated or
is it everywhere at the moment
um
so i would be vigilant about the
language
that your schools are using um if they
if if frequently you see or if the
number the one thing they see on their
on your website on that school's website
is diversity and inclusion or equity
or we want to um
affirm students um
remember
remember
that that is the exact language that is
used in the critical pedagogy literature
in the sense that they're
they're they're trying to
make students um sort of be wide awake
um to all of the structures that are
oppressing them and the term inclusion
implies that currently society or
whatever
or the world is against you or is
excluding you so it's actually appealing
to your sense of marginalization if you
see language that is appealing
to
your kids
sense of marginalization i would i would
avoid that i would avoid that school
okay
and it's happening too it is happening
in private schools too um there is there
is an elite
private school in boston massachusetts
called the windsor school for all girls
that i got a chance as a journalist i
reviewed some of the diversity equity
and inclusion documents and the language
is all about uh you know deconstructing
systemic racism and we want to
deconstruct linguistic racism which is
basically how are you going to get a job
like what's the long-term plan with this
you go to university and they teach you
how to deconstruct literature
how is anyone going to pay you to do
that
they do
you know you so that that's a classic
conservative argument against all this
you know you're not gonna be able to get
a job good luck with that yeah um but
the the the issue with that argument is
that they actually are creating an
industry to pay you to do this stuff but
there is there is now the diversity
equity and inclusion industry is now a
10 billion plus industry it is found in
every fortune 500 company and your job
is to pedal this kind of
narrative wow
so you asked that the problem the
problem now
is not just that you're being taught
these things in college the problem is
now is that you can actually be paid to
do these things to other people and
perpetuate this ideology to other people
that's the problem
that's a huge problem
hmm
okay
okay so you said that there's this
there's this fight with
some of the asian students at harvard
and they're trying to they're at the
supreme court level
trying to shut down the race-based
preference
preferences that harvard has so that
could change things
is
this is a tricky this is a tricky battle
to have
what's your goal with your book
i want to make
i want to make the world aware
of the consequences of anti-racism
and just because i've seen it myself in
my own eyes in the college admissions
process which is effectively an
anti-racist admissions policy
um it's been happening for the past 30
years harvard's been doing this for the
past 30 years
and what i see
ultimately is it's a penalization
of of of people who want to succeed
cultures who want to be excellent
cultures you want to be academically
excellent you know if asian americans
want to be academically excellent we
should reward that if people if there
are some cultures you want to be
athletically excellent or business
excellent or excellent at music or
excellent at the arts we should reward
that you know there are a
disproportionate number of black
americans in the nba today what are we
gonna do are we gonna say well there's
too few white americans we gotta put
more white americans into the nba
you know or they're two they're
disproportionately more jewish americans
right now who want to go
into the arts
and um that's that's their that's what
they should do we should reward that
but if if a culture
decides that they want to be
to pursue academic math and science stem
excellence
or excellence of any kind academically
then we should reward that as well and
we are progressing from a culture right
now
that is transitioning away from
meritocracy judging people on their
merits to a culture that is judging
people on the basis of their background
again and i i want i want to make the
world aware of the consequences of what
that's going to happen
[Music]
yeah
this is this is scary too because it's
not exactly happening everywhere it's
happening really badly in north america
and i would say western europe but there
are other places around the world that
don't care about this at all and so
they're all going based on
meritocracy right who does what best and
then give them more resources which is
going to progress their society way
faster than whatever we're doing and
unfortunately like i think people
especially who are pushing some of these
theories
they're just stuck in north america
they're not even aware that there are
other places out there that are going to
be like you know something else could
become the next superpower that aren't
focused on things like stopping people
from pursuing sciences which seems like
a silly thing to do and then spending a
bunch of money on proving why that's a
good idea
yeah
no
you're right michaela i mean it's um
look at china
china um
went through the cultural revolution
where basically they took all of the
intellectuals and they took all of the
um
all the people who were the best farmers
the best workers the best laborers and
they put them to re-education camp and
they got rid of the universities they
got rid of the merit-based admissions
process they admitted people based on
political ideology and as a result what
was this
this was in the 1960s to the 1970s under
mao zedong
okay and
basically their entire country went
through a brain drain
and they fled to other countries the
chinese fled to other countries like the
united states
like western europe like india
um the philippines
uh vietnam another place um and so and
um
and it caused a massive brain drain in
their country and they're they're
actually still recovering from that
today um
so they they understand the
consequences
of destroying meritocracy in this
country and you know we are
unfortunately on that road as well
oh yeah that's scary i feel like okay so
that was china and then
the same similar thing happened in
germany right a whole bunch of jewish
people left and a lot of that then came
to america
and then the same thing happened in
soviet union a lot a lot of the super
educated people left and came to america
which made america a very interesting
place to be filled with a whole bunch of
immigrants that were incredibly smart
and now we're doing the same thing
because everyone's forgotten what
happened
that is so true that is so true
um and it's funny you mentioned the
soviet union
um there was a there's a professor that
i interviewed from princeton named
sergey kleinerman
math professor from this from what used
to be the soviet union and
or satellite state i forget which
and he said
to me and i asked him why did you study
math and he said
penny
math was the only place was the only
subject that i could study where i felt
like i could study the truth because
everything else that i studied
was going to be repressed and my work
would have vanished
oh
that's creepy it's funny so everybody
has this stereotype of like eastern
european intellectuals like being really
good at math or chess or something like
that
okay what people don't understand is
that the reason why so many of them
flocked to math
was actually they're actually just smart
they could have done a lot of things
they could have done arts they could
have done business
but the culture was so hostile to both
of those other things the only place
that they felt like they could have a
refuge to actually pursue the truth was
in that
oh that's creepy
that's like i felt not to put myself in
the same shoes as what happened in the
ussr or anything but definitely when i
was taking classics in psychology i can
remember studying homework through a
feminist lens it wasn't what the course
said but i got there and i was like yeah
this is homer through a feminist lens
and i was just like
what
as if homer was thinking about that
like what about homer through a homer
lens but
and then switching into biomedical
science i was like ah okay i'll just
ignore it and this is when dad was all
up in arms being like
people are taking over the humanities
the world is ending
i was like the sciences are fine don't
worry about it and then it started
infiltrating the sciences
um and i don't know what it's like now
but
that's scary that similarity is scary
you said when you were taking math did
you have people come in to teach about
anything like crt or was it in
textbooks like or had it not infiltrated
yet what does the infiltration look like
yeah it's funny you mentioned math um i
just finished up a long form article
about
crt and math um so
the uh
the
with the new trend right now and i
didn't really see this in my school but
also that's kind of because i i selected
into courses that i and professors that
i felt would actually teach math the
right way
so and i was largely right um
but
the the what's the new trend is
inclusive now um is inclusive math which
is
uh basically
um
you know we need to
there that the the the premise behind
inclusive math is that
um
you know
we need to
try all of these new tactics to
sort of
people who other we need to get a
person's interest in math going like so
basically your objective is to make
people interested in math because once
they're interested in math and they love
math then yeah they're just going to
learn all by themselves math and they
won't need a teacher ever again
so your objective is to make math fun
um and exciting for a person and
relevant to a person the other word is
relevant
um so uh you know as a result of
inclusive math you have these textbooks
called the heart what is called the
heart of mathematics that is you know
sort of playing you know that is chapter
titles like fun fun with numbers you
know and these are for college students
these are for college students and
yes if you read this textbook it's like
it's it's it's fun
but
this textbook does not is not going to
prepare you
with a
systems of equations it's not going to
prepare you with uh linear polynomials
it's not going to prepare you with the
prerequisites to calculus uh so
ultimately all it really is is a
lowering of standards in the name of
diversity and inclusion
so i forgot that the idea there is that
you know people who aren't interested in
math and physics aren't interested
because they haven't been taught
properly or something it's not as if you
know
men maybe like math better
that it's not that is that people aren't
taught
to enjoy it properly
right i think it's i think it's yeah
people people think that the reason why
some people can't do math is just
because they're not excited about and
the truth is no the reason why some
people can't do math is because
they
they were badly taught
they were poorly told and it's really
really difficult at that level you
actually have to be really smart in
order to understand math it's well
it's it's a little different
maybe you're underestimating yourself i
wasn't okay i
i
you if you challenge a person at the
appropriate level you can actually move
a person through math education fairly
quickly even if that person is somewhat
of a slower learner the problem with
their math education today or classes
today is that they're putting like
really high speed high level students in
the same classroom with kids who are
still learning one plus one so if you're
in first grade already there are
discrepancies in a person's intellectual
capability to comprehend math you have a
person who cannot even add
to a person you know sitting next to a
person who can already who already knows
multiplication yeah yeah and when you're
a teacher when you're a single teacher
and you have no ability sorting because
you're not allowed to do ability sorted
right now because it's inequitable um
but you if you're a teacher you have to
teach the middle so what happens is that
the the guy who's really good at math
doesn't get a challenging education he
gets really bored and he's not learning
as much math as he could learn while the
child who's at the bottom of the heap is
getting completely confused and it's not
learning math at the level that he
should be learned so this this entire
crt dominated equity phenomenon is
destroying math education for kids i i
sincerely believe that anybody really
can learn math if they're taught at the
appropriate speed
okay so i want to go back i think to
maybe we should talk about how people
can actually succeed because peop people
are taught okay you're stuck in this box
of race or disability or
being a woman or being trans or whatever
little box you're put into
and
being taught that you're stuck in a box
kind of artificially limits what you can
do right if you're brainwashed into
believing that there's a ceiling you
can't
pass
then you're just trapped there so are
there ways
that people should be thinking and i
rather than
looking at all the problems in their
life and how those are stopping them
is there a different mindset that people
should have in order to actually succeed
in life
um
i think that the wisdom of the crowd
is
underrated
um everybody wants to be
[Music]
a
a rebel
everybody wants to be a cowboy
in america we have those archetypes for
a reason um because they inspire
innovation and they're really great but
in order to be an effective cowboy you
need to know how to carry a gun you need
to know how to ride a horse
and
i think
um if you want to be
an effective uh person at your career
you need to learn how to speak well you
need to learn how to
you know
understand and speak proper english
and to have a have a dense vocabulary
that conveys that you know what you're
talking about
you need to have
basic
math and conceptual skills
to be able to
um
uh
show other people
that you are capable of solving problems
and getting them right and getting them
done efficiently
[Music]
you should belong you should make some
sort of effort
to acquire a social community where you
can acquire social status where there is
a hierarchy that you can move up through
now it doesn't mean if it's a completely
corrupt hierarchy than avoided all costs
as you know you and i have been talking
about tequila in our college education
there are corrupt hierarchies you need
to recognize that but you need to find
some sort of social group that you can
that you can sort of move up that has
values in its cultures and assimilate
and acclimate to that culture
because that ultimately makes you a more
competitive person
and you know by being a more competitive
person you become
um you know a person who can sort of
understand and play different games and
and uh will be able to to succeed better
at
any one of them so i think that's some
of the advice that i would give based on
my research and some of the experience
that i've been given
how do you feel about people doing free
work for other people like finding a
mentor and then working for free because
i know when i was in university that was
looked down on a lot because everybody's
broke so you're like oh well it's free
work what's the purpose of that but then
when i started actually meeting people
who were really smart
if you just find a really smart person
and you start helping them they'll
appreciate and then you get free
education that way and that's
potentially depending on the person more
valuable than whatever you're going to
be learning in school
yeah oh that's i mean that's hey i think
it's really interesting um
free work
um depends how much work right
i guess i guess the uh
i guess the example
or i guess the comparison would you ask
is like would you rather work for
uh 15 bucks an hour at mcdonald's or
would you rather work for free um
next to neil degrasse tyson you know
and the answer is you'd rather work for
free next to neil degrasse tyson
um
so if you have options i suggest you
take them you know align yourself with
somebody who is competitive and
succeeding um academically athletically
in a business sense i mean i if i'm for
it as long as it doesn't of course take
over your life and as long as they're
not exploiting you
yes
yeah yeah
so what's next for you what's your plan
for the next year
um i'm on tour for an inconvenient
minority um i
am swan president of color us united and
you know we are a race blind advocacy
group um we do campaigns you know to ask
uh
and to to force the hand of nonprofits
and corporations who are pushing woke
ideology
um our big campaign right now is with
the salvation army actually um they just
ask their members they're such a good
organization it's so sad they just ask
their members to repent for racism um
they're you know like uh
because this because these members are
definitely the least racist people that
you could possibly imagine in the
salvation army you know um so you know
where we gathered 10 thousand signatures
so we're organizing getting employees
it's colorist united dot org um
gathering employees you know and and
pushing the the resistance
against crt
and woke ideology in all facets of our
life
have you got a lot of negative feedback
from doing that
no uh
i know the majority of americans want to
race blind society um yeah i was part of
the campaign
in california
last year basically some a group of crt
advocates and
lawmakers
what you know wanted california to
reinstitute race preferences
and admissions and public contracting so
if you were a certain race you could get
a leg up but if you're another race
you'd get a kick down
um and
they put it to a vote
you know california not exactly a
conservative stronghold voted 57 percent
to 43 no on that proposition so i know
the majority of americans are behind
colorblindness and i will continue to to
to co-stop that doesn't mean i haven't
gotten negative feedback but
um i think it's it is a worthy idea that
we should be pushing
awesome okay well you mentioned a few
websites but just to reiterate if people
want to follow you um where should they
go online
you can go on my twitter uh
kennymshu and like mary
um
or my instagram same thing follow me on
youtube kennyshu that's my channel
and that's my podcast my podcast is the
inconvenient minority podcast
and then go to colorrestunited.org to
learn more
sweet thank you very much for coming on
thank you
[Music]
you